now there's a lot out there but certain
shoes like especially dunks dunks are
like right now done sb dunks are like
the hot what our dunks did you see the
shoes times why do you act like this why
do you ruin every conversation you just
ruin every girl why you're like my dad
be cool the second ones in the Valentine
sense those are dope Papa just got those
that's cool I swear you're so annoying
why I'm stronger dope those are sick by
the way though I gotta hook you up with
my urine uh El Paso no that's in San
Antonio buddy boy Jake does custom shoes
for LeBron Beckham everybody got me
custom custom supreme ones low tops show
him those chin Brian go get a son
[ __ ] know I want to be part of this
oh I love some friendless kicks you know
what I hate the most is like this would
be such a great conversation yeah you're
ruining I'm not doing anything out your
ruining old I'm listening you're being
very old no I'm not I'm saying it's like
fresh and boto those are small there's a
sick so he makes them for Nike he make
he gets the all the the all the the
materials are from where Nike gets
theirs oh really and just refurbished is
the whole thing does it own style oh
this is so good I'm really like a really
detailed how do they get that dope that
dope you're annoying
Wow Wow get back on set bro I'm
literally just sitting here as an actor
as a working actor then time offer you
how much time again how long does it
take you to remember your three lines in
that show no first of all like three
that's a [ __ ] anything mistakes on the
star and also I have a photographic
memory
yeah and no one believed that that's why
I was a completely July it
I remember the internet shut down you
know what my new goal is dead serious
shut up I'm not shutting the [ __ ] up
please shut the [ __ ] up
but I'm not taking myself seriously yeah
no more at all no I don't
at all III know do it starts to you know
you really need fish oil for those
joints right but your joint no that
wasn't a point down what you're getting
here
no I opened myself up and now you guys
are being fixed about my eight I know
you gave me a really nice compliment
about how yeah and then you went right
to your knees and how how you don't have
time the time is uh limited now cuz
you're you're on the other side now the
back you're on the other side though
yeah you're having down the hill and
come back now you don't want us to
respect a lot of time climbing up that
hill but now you're [ __ ] your role in
my own thank you yes I'm gonna have a
yes I'm gonna have my day have your day
bro you're called back on this said yeah
but I'm just not sound like 30,000 taken
sama Philip no you're not
well actually that's just the two shows
the San Francisco if you add up the
whole weekend it's close to what we
figure out you okay 60,000 okay all
right Joe I'm trying to sell it the West
Palm Beach improv this weekend I'll be
there for Valentine's Day Friday
Saturday something I'm [ __ ] quitting
stamp how many times have I asked you to
come to my show and to be honest I've
asked you so many times to come do my
show you mean that you're to come on my
show to go to go up and perform I've
asked you and I've asked Brett I'll calm
him once
let me come to a tight out I don't give
a [ __ ] that's not what I want from you
okay you just you just I want to keep
them there I want to contain them yeah
cuz you wanna leave it all the whole
goal yeah man the whole goal is to keep
them in there for a certain amount of
time give them a [ __ ] show
yeah so you would go in there three like
salt pepper like a little three four
minutes you know whatever your that's no
no it's something do I fly up myself and
the night no I don't fly you I got a
private jet you got like ah you're like
10 open seats but like but uh so
generous I believe if I reach in I'm
just joking by the way you know that
right we get serious
thanks Joe wait you know what that's my
camera which one's my that was the only
way if you had worked on in your face
cuz you look tight no no it's that's
Asian so like when you have Asian ji
yeah you don't get that many lines
across the forehead right so yours is
like like a tree like when you cut a
tree if you count I say to the tree so
shitty degree there's like seven rings
put your piece of sorry every ring is
ten years sure yeah so that's like I say
it's more like a packet of Baker don't
have a pack of bacon yeah yeah say that
about my face man I'm wearing makeup so
the the eleventh okay so you know when
you cut a tree yes and you see the Rings
I hate this plant account
you can't count how old the tree is and
buy the Rings I know you says you like
when you like like raise your eyebrows
no just raise your eyebrows no that's a
black surprise real quick like look up
look up Wow yeah that each line is like
seven years no it's not how did you kept
count ten no don't what is seven times
six I'm bad at math it's like 79 or 42
40 there's the other thing so then
that's wrong yeah yeah that's wrong it
wants peace do it again one more time
fine I'm gonna do it again but don't I
won't no you know me I'm not shitty come
on oh you forgot the line in the middle
of his eyebrows Hey so seven times eight
is fifty-six your your head is like dog
ears each line is like seven years can't
say my face the tree and like dog years
you can't say that there's eight lines
across your head no there's times that
by seven times eight is what it if I get
my times eight is what right seven times
eight 56 58 how old are you I'm 53 boom
Brian Brian Brian slingback unis lids
done though yeah are you yeah we've
talked about I can't see well I've aged
that's the difference between 49 and 53
that right eyelid you can't see my eyes
yeah it's like he has a visor over both
eyes now and it's from years of boxing
sports well it's [ __ ] it's far still
[ __ ] by the way [ __ ] I [ __ ] well yeah
well who knows but here's my question
you still [ __ ] oh look at you blank face
huh yeah
I don't know now you're a prude look at
you I don't want to talk about that with
you you just smile you just swallowed
with your mouth open you a man you might
be a phony sixty thousand tickets my ass
are you dip no no no that's real though
you should have seen that deposit I made
today and it's real tight and if you
want to challenge me on a bet no I'll
pull it out I brought my back man no
just in case I don't know hold for all
it you want to go wallet for wallet oh
yes blood since you were bragging about
that goddamn TV set you got to get to
know but that's it when we were getting
copy Brett were you right next to me
Brendon when he said that yeah you did
it goes what I gotta reaping let's get
this pot I gotta get to the TV set if
you I'll add pretty more lapped hard but
awesome
want to do it you want to settle the bet
wallet for wall oh that's so gauche now
I'm just saying I have an envelope full
of money you can challenge that or you
can go with the deposit slips I did Sam
Tripp what everyone I got [ __ ] cash
on me too he cried yeah but I have a lot
I'm awesome
so I was I was I was blessed in high
school you were athletic really
good-looking so I never had any problems
and I was funny how crazy your hair was
thinning and your face was always old
does that so big that's an unfair thing
I saw a baby picture of your face take
it back and usually well usually babies
have a lot of wrinkles and they go he'll
grow into it yeah cuz it's loose skin
yeah you've never grown into it you
still have the wrinkles there it's such
a jerk to me right now I would stop
sunbathing
I don't son I would stop sunbathe I stay
out of the Sun I'm on set all day that's
that soundstage in front of your lights
lights lights lights life well this is
uh I'm really uh jealous of your success
hey your feets are casually like that
stop laughing a shadow
hey hope yours you're being a jerk dude
I'm proud of my [ __ ] Tina hey Bo I
love your show it's very funny your cast
is amazing Tim come on Tim is amazing
why don't you come get your wrap already
be this last week got four more episodes
I still
Oh what he lied to us you said this is
last week that is true he did say that
no I said you don't know I was doing
jump on the bandwagon I remember that
yeah I remember you saying that and
you're like this my lat yeah you know I
know
Lila you're doing a good thing Wow what
did you study
yeah I studied cut-up I didn't know that
yeah that was clearly a [ __ ] I am I
mean I study and I know the difference
yeah let me see your face we need a Yoda
oh there's there's a lot of cuts and are
you sure a guy trained secretly yeah Wow
I'll fight man what as long as there's
sharp objects or glass around you're
down I'm gonna use it if I come at you
Chicago diner 15 years ago what happened
so if I come at you you I'll throw
something at your [ __ ] face
well what's crazy is your face is made
of leather No so won't know you've been
you don't cut you've been mean about you
don't cut okay I bleed just like
everybody else
yes I do I believe just like everybody
else and I cry and and I you ever tried
tear the leather in half yeah you can't
impossible that's your face no no that's
your face where's my camera you're being
so rude and I mean is it the slow one
yeah it's the big one it's a big one
no the big one okay man wealth has made
you such a jerk to dr. Long's OPP now
I'm gonna die really yeah you [ __ ] did
we go to break no keep going
no unite you know I kind of connect like
yeah yeah yeah we're actually it's
actually probably better a fighter in
the koi that's right but yeah uh fighter
in the koi well there's a K already
there can you record that can you record
that yeah I want this documented there's
already a K so the fighter and the koi
kind of flows so do your set bro which
one's my camera right which one's the
camera sorry before you guys do this can
I ask Brian a serious question and don't
get it don't get mad at me don't be
shitty
huh well have I been yes very much so
worst of all time now now be nice what
were you gonna ask I'm just gonna ask
you okay have you memorized your line
the one line Joe that's a shitty you're
being you're being a dick and your fake
sucking that right now you know who's on
roids
oh no I'm not don't nod to me like that
don't spread rumors about me just
because I'm naturally muscular
Leatherface oh no don't call me
Leatherface do you have a picture blur
face gosh I could pull it up pull up
pull up leather face and tell me this is
it Bryan Callen just like waking up in
the morning that's upright talent no
that's up right early in the morning no
no before you put on moisturizer
oh that's soap right there I bought that
mask before on Halloween it's called the
Bryan Callen
that's called the Bryan Callen is it
Netflix of the mr. rinks [ __ ] jokes
and I talked about doing a TV show maybe
sold them sell shirts that say rah rah
rah rah rah rah rah rah
hey you bro you [ __ ] you in your [ __ ]
dress right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]